Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Emma Gon
¿Qué tan grande fue ese pez
que capturastes?
¿Así de grande?
¿O así de grande?
Sin evidencia fotográfica,
no hay prueba de que
capturastes algo gigantesco
y esa es la verdad desde
los albores de la pesca.
De hecho, cientos de años atrás.
mucho antes de que la fotografía
llegara para capturar el momento,
los pescadores japoneses
inventaron su propia forma
de registrar las capturas trofeos.
La llamaron Gyotaku.
El Gyotaku es el arte antiguo
de estampar peces
que se originó en Japón
como una forma de registrar
las capturas trofeos
antes de la cámara
moderna de hoy en día.
Gyo significa pez
y taku significa impresión.
Existen muchísimas historias acerca
del origen de Gyotaku,
pero básicamente comenzó
porque los pescadores
necesitaban documentar de alguna forma
las especies y el tamaño
de los peces que capturaban
desde hace más de 100 años.
Los pescadores llevaban
papel, tinta y pinceles
consigo al mar.
Contaban historias de grandes
aventuras en el mar.
Como algunos japoneses
reverenciaban algunos tipos de peces,
los pescadores sacaban
el estampado de estos peces,
y luego los devolvían al mar.
Para hacer el estampado
se pintaba al pez
con tinta no tóxica sumi-e
y se estampaba sobre
papel de arroz.
De esta forma se podía
devolver al mar
o limpiarse y venderse
en el mercado.
Estampados iniciales como estos
se hicieron solo para registro
y carecían de detalles adicionales.
No fue sino hasta
mediados de 1800
que se comenzó a pintar los ojos
y otros detalles en la impresión.
Un noble famoso, Lord Sakai,
era un pescador ávido
y cuando pescó algo grande
quiso tener un recuerdo
del gran besugo del mar rojo.
Para ello le encargó a un pescador
que estampara su captura.
Después de esto,
muchos pescadores le llevaban
sus estampados de Gyotaku
a Lord Sakai,
que si le gustaba
los contrataba para que
le hicieran sus estampados.
Muchos estampados colgaban
en el palacio durante el período Edo.
Después de este período,
el Gyotaku ya no fue tan popular
y comenzó a desaparecer.
Hoy en día, el Gyotaku se ha vuelto
una forma popular de arte
que muchos disfrutan.
Y se dice que los estampados
le dan suerte a los pescadores.
Pero esta forma de arte
es muy diferente a lo que solía ser.
Hoy en día, la mayoría de los artistas aprenden
por su cuenta mediante ensayo y error.
Antes que el artista
comience a estampar
se necesita preparar
al pez para el estampado.
Primero, el artista coloca el pez
sobre una superficie ahuecada.
Luego, el artista extiende las aletas
y las clava sobre la superficie
para secarlas.
Luego, el pez se limpia con agua.
Para realizar el estampado
existen dos métodos diferentes.
El método indirecto comienza adhiriendo
una pieza de tela o papel humedecido
sobre el pez
usando pasta de arroz.
Luego, el artista utiliza un tompo
o una bola de algodón
cubierta con seda
para aplicar la tinta sobre la tela
o papel y realizar el estampado.
Este método requiere
de más destreza
y se debe tener mucho cuidado
cuando se retira el papel del pez
para que esta no se desgarre.
En el método directo
el artista pinta directamente
sobre el pez
y luego presiona la tela o papel
humedecido suavemente sobre el pez.
Con ambos métodos
ninguna impresión
sale exactamente igual,
pero con ambos se logran
imágenes impresionantes del pez.
Para el toque final
el artista utiliza
una marca o sello
para firmar su obra,
y así mostrarla y decir,
"¡El pez era exactamente
así de grande!"